E aí a pergunta que
eu vou precisar
fazer agora pra
gente começar a
falar sobre o nosso
tema principal é
você é engajado ou
você é comprometido
Não precisa explicar
essas imagens aqui
não né não precisa
explicar tá muito
claro isso
mas sabe que eu
passei muito tempo
quando eu comecei a
escrever o livro
tentando encontrar
o melhor conceito
para falar sobre
engajamento eu
estudei muito eu
busquei pensadores o
que
as pessoas falavam
sobre o que é ser
uma pessoa engajada
e sabe onde eu
encontrei
o meu melhor
conceito sobre
engajamento no
dicionário foi o
último lugar que eu
procurei
e no dicionário
falava assim
engajamento é fazer
por livre espontânea
vontade aquilo
que tem que ser
feito olha que
definição linda não
é bonito isso fazer
por livre
espontânea vontade o
que tem que ser
feito então qual é a
definição de
engajamento
liberdade eu faço o
que quero fazer e
qual a definição de
comprometimento
fazer
porque precisa fazer
então enquanto
engajamento é
liberdade
comprometimento é
necessidade